[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive
it's time to see what's making the
headlines with broadcaster and former
conservative special adviser anita
buateng and senior associate editor from
the new statesman rachel cunliffe
they'll be with us from now right the
way up until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
the eye highlights the growing pressure
on the prime minister over his partygate
fine and refusal to resign
the paper says he now fears an avalanche
of other fines as the investigations
into illegal gatherings continue
same story in the guardian which says
senior conservatives think he could face
a leadership challenge within weeks
meanwhile as the mail reports boris
johnson is offering to send tanks to
ukraine to help the country repel the
latest russian offensive
the telegraph says that an eu report has
revealed that france and germany both
sold millions of pounds worth of arms to
russia that are probably now being used
in the war in ukraine
the mirror reports that the german man
suspected of abducting madeleine mccann
has been named a formal suspect and
questioned in jail by police from
portugal
the sun leads with the bomb and death
threats made against manchester united
footballer harry maguire by hat the
paper calls what the paper calls a
maniac
the time says the health secretary is
launching an inquiry into the treatment
of vulnerable children who he believes
are wrongly being given gender hormone
treatment by the nhs
the financial times leads with the slump
in uk consumer spending which has helped
push the pound to its lowest in two
years and raise fears
of a looming recession
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by anita
watang and rachel kunlifer welcome to
you both good evening let's start with
the i weekend their front page and uh
the headline there johnson fear's
avalanche of fines as tory unrest grows
uh it does seem that his situation has
changed very quickly in a very short
space of time in terms of the support
that he has um especially from his own
backbenchers rachel
well yes i think yesterday was really
the the day when everything changed
because the fact is uh had number 10
believed that they had the support in
the house they wouldn't have gone along
with with labour's motion they only did
that yesterday and they only allowed mps
to nod through um
an inquiry into whether the prime
minister misled parliament and break the
ministerial code they only did that
because they weren't certain that they
were going to win
if they tried to fight it or even if
they did win they thought that it would
um be incredibly embarrassing if a high
number of conservative mps abstained or
voted against the prime minister so that
that vote or that that rather that lack
of vote tells you everything you need to
know about waning support for boris
johnson among his backbenchers and
that's before you get to the issue of
further fines which is what it looks
like we're going to see now we're not
going to see them in the next two weeks
before the local election at least not
from the metropolitan police who have
said in a slightly odd bit of uh
logic that they don't want to influence
the result of the elections therefore
they're not going to
release information about any further
fines you could argue that withholding
information about whether or not the
prime minister had confined to breaking
his own covert laws is in itself
influencing the local elections but even
arguments about about that aside um
fines are happening people have been
getting emails about them pretty much as
we speak downing street uh whitehall
it's all very leaky at the moment so we
probably will hear about them uh and
that's just a drip drip drip of more
trouble and more embarrassment for the
prime minister as his support is already
on the wane
yes and there has to be said that there
is a thought that there will be some
sort of move after the may elections a
quote here from a uh tory mp unnamed on
the front page but just saying that that
has to be the time when we move against
him anita
well i think i'm not quite so doom and
gloom the i paid the front page is
obviously um very dramatic talking about
an avalanche and boris junk the mood
amongst tory mps darkening and i think
this week was definitely very
challenging because mps tory mps were
essentially being told we're going to
put an amendment down
um to a labor motion that basically
doesn't say no one should investigate
the issue of whether or not boris
johnson knowingly misled the house but
we should just put down a motion that
says let's do it later and i think that
was tricky because tory mps felt like
they might be sort of marched up the
hill um to argue against an
investigation right now from the commons
privileges committee but in a couple of
weeks or after the um the suga report
comes out there might then be a moment
where there would end up being a
referral to the commons privileged
committee and so they felt as though if
that's inevitable why not just just
concede right now um so i think it's
less about actually the the substance of
whether or not they feel that boris
johnson has behaved in the right way
but more that sense that victoria mps
worry about being marched up various
hills or worry about having to defend
and constantly talk about this issue and
most of them do sort of want the issue
to go away now i think there's a
considerable and sensible question that
you could ask julian and your readers
might ask which is like it doesn't seem
to be going away and in the event of
that scenario what do tory mps do
i sort of understand why a series of
them are saying well we will move after
the local elections i still think it's
probably too early to predict
that um that that is what's going to
happen but that is a moment of
considerable danger for the prime
minister so so you do agree that the
mood has changed
well
i guess what i'm saying is that this
week it was much more about kind of
parliamentary protocol i just think that
mps were content not to be talking about
this are frustrated to be talking about
it again but that doesn't translate into
okay we need mo votes or letters of no
confidence in and we need a vote of no
confidence right now i'm not sensing
that that has significantly shifted this
week and the cost of living crisis up
most on many people's minds um number 10
apparently spooked by an opinion poll
which shows the tour is not trusted on
the economy so all of that's into the
mix isn't it rachel
yeah and that is is arguably a far more
important issue than than partygate um a
little pitch for the new statesman we
we've launched a project called state of
the nation where we are um tracking a
whole load of things including opinion
polling and one of my excellent
colleagues has done some work on this
question of who is most trusted on the
economy and it's really interesting
because if you ask voters you know who
do you want in downing street sometimes
labor's up in the polls sometimes
tourism up in the polls it kind of comes
and goes but historically it's very very
difficult for labour to get a lead on
who is trusted on the economy that's
that's i mean they're the party of the
nhs maybe in the tories of the party of
of managing the economy that has has
changed and the tories are no longer
trusted on it the other thing that's
really interesting is that when you ask
voters kind of what does managing the
economy well mean if you'd asked them 10
years ago it would it was about managing
the deficit and managing the nation's
finances you know sound finance and all
that stuff that we can remember from the
coalition government if you ask them now
it's much more about employment and the
cost of living and actually the sense
that if you are a government and you are
uh allowing so many people to plunge
into such deep economic suffering and
let's be clear it's only going to get
worse from this point onwards uh with
energy and tax rises and slowing growth
and we'll come on to some of that later
but if you are the government and you
are allowing that to happen you cannot
be trusted on the economy and that puts
the conservatives i think in a much more
dangerous position than just who would
you rather see in downing street boris
or kiss dama let's move on to the
daily mail
anita and this story that boris johnson
is promising thanks
to ukraine but it's not actually
directly from the the uk he's promising
to to backfill
poland essentially so poland will send
the tanks and the the uk would
then give new tanks to poland so the
headline slightly uh misleading anita
yes it's very much a sort of a parcel
parcel so the uk compensates poland if
poland ends up providing these t-72
tanks to ukraine um and actually the mod
has tweeted saying that there's no
decisions have been taken but are
suggesting that these these tanks could
be deployed on a short-term basis so it
certainly feels like it's in the ether
and you know the prime minister has been
very clear and and continues to be so
even from his trip in india about the
kind of force of support the uk is
providing to ukraine it's really
interesting that the conversation is now
moving from defensive
armory of the ukrainians to stuff that
would be more offensive that could
potentially turn the tide in the
conflict and i think we're going to go
on to talk about really france and
germany and where they sit in that
debate in considering how much they want
to be proactive in helping ukraine to
sort of push russian forces back and
ultimately to win because there is
obviously the challenge with that of
further escalation from vladimir putin
so this is something where you might see
a little more fracturing in the very
very strong and united european alliance
so far yes and this comes at a time when
the prime minister is saying that russia
could
win this war
rachel
uh
yeah uh well we know that the the
fighting has intensified and we can get
a sort of clearer sense of of what the
goals now are um you know putin pushing
in the east and the south wanting a a
land bridge to
crimea um i think what we've learned
over the last sort of two months since
this invasion began is putin is highly
unlikely to give up until he is forced
to
um and that all of the early speculation
that maybe it was a ruse and or not a
ruse but a sort of a
sort of show of strength and that if we
just negotiated in the right way or we
got the right sanctions and we responded
that maybe he'd stop um i think the
general consensus among um foreign
policy analyst at the moment is that
that isn't going to happen and and
that's why military support to ukraine
from the uk whether it's via poland or
or some other way and via other
countries is so important to the
telegraph anita and this uh well
embarrassing story it must be at this
point in time france and germany armed
russia with 230 million pounds of
military hardware that is likely being
used in ukraine
yes so the telegraph have alighted on a
european commissions or a slight
loophole that basically says that you
can sell equipment to russia if it's got
dual use so it can be used for civilians
and also militarily and they think that
230 million pounds has been given to
france and germany and we're talking
about rifles special protection
equipment thermal imaging cameras and so
this has now obviously been um
outlawed as a result of additional
european sanctions but nevertheless
there is a suggestion here from the
telegraph that france and germany are
not being as fulsome and proactive in
their support um as as the uk is and
that this is kind of a considerable
embarrassment for russia and for germany
and for france yes i mean it really is
isn't it
rachel
oh yeah certainly there are a couple of
things that really stood out for me in
this uh one of which is that this
loophole was only closed in the fifth
round of sanctions so the first four
rounds of eu sanctions they kept this
loophole open that enables
eu nations to sell arms to russia that
are then used against ukraine um the the
second one was that was germany's
defense saying that these export
licenses wouldn't have been granted
unless it was guaranteed that they were
for civilian use okay and if you'll
believe that i've got a bridge to sell
you and goodness knows what else sure
putin yeah i'll have all these rifles
for civilian use definitely nothing to
do with anything else nope um
and then the third thing that kind of
struck me in this is that the eu is is
still paying russia obviously for energy
supplies and that's a bit more
complicated but they're paying
1 billion euros per day so if you look
at how for example that the cost of oil
has spiked during this crisis um
in a way putin is is managing to balance
the book because uh yes there are
sanctions but the resource that that
russia has oil and gas the prices are
shooting up and he's being able to to
fund his war and russia is profiting in
in that way so i think very important
conversations when we talk about
what the west can do to hold russia to
account you've got to look at these
numbers
have a look at the ft the pound is not
looking very healthy
anita
yes
a fairly dramatic story from the ft here
about falling high street sales and they
fell 1.4 not the 0.3 predicted by the
ons you've got plunging consumer
confidence rapidly calling business
activity it's a fairly kind of avalanche
of different factors that the ft warns
um is is contributing to a massive fall
in the pound um which is now kind of a
low not seen since 2020 um and as part
of this story well worth the read um it
talks about the bank of england's fears
over inflation so how do you call
inflation without causing a recession
and pretty much you know in in uk um
economic history there hasn't been a
time where in recession hasn't been the
thing that's ended a period of very high
inflation and the bank of england now
saying the kind of
its opportunity or its ability to knock
off inflation without leading to a
recession is kind of becoming harder and
harder so really an indication of some
of the troubles that the uk economy may
be in in the coming months
yes and andrew bailey the bank of
england governor saying he hoped the
bank could still pull off a soft landing
but warned it was a narrow path a
difficult job ahead for him
rachel
yeah he's essentially walking a
tightrope there between as anita said
between uh trying to curb inflation and
trying to make sure that the economy
doesn't go into a recession and it looks
like britain is kind of uniquely uh in a
poor position at this point because
other countries are dealing with uh
um inflation from uh wage pressures like
like the us and other countries like in
europe are dealing from inflation from
high energy costs and
we're kind of sort of uniquely
in the middle of it all so wages are
being squeezed costs are going up and no
one's spending anything which is slowing
the economy the most terrifying thing
about this article is is some quotes
from some of the financial analysts in
it uh that the worst is is yet to come
and that the dam is breaking and
actually that the picture later on this
year particularly in the autism of
winter could be a whole lot worse anita
just very quickly on the consumer
confidence and post-pandemic it was
thought that people
saved up quite a lot of money not going
anywhere or doing anything and that they
would then um flood the high streets not
happened
absolutely no and i think that was a lot
of the hope um and part of that is just
people thinking about some of the
challenges in terms of uncertainty as
rachel says around the future and
obviously the higher costs of inflation
beginning to bite and energy bills don't
forget we are in
um april the weather's been quite lovely
but but come the autumn even the
existing energy price even if it doesn't
go up any higher and not many people
think that that's going to be the case
the the bills that people might be
looking at coming into the autumn will
be very difficult indeed and so i quite
understand why consumers are not
splashing the cash and are continuing um
to tighten their belts in anticipation
of things becoming more difficult but
obviously then you're in a spiral um
where that lack of consumer confidence
and that lack of spending serves to
dampen business confidence anita and
rachel thank you both